foreign
when he gets to go and take the lead
uh
foreign
three points
Drew Williams
you're gonna lock down dph coaching
Channel Drive
foreign
[Music]
approximately 60.
foreign
services
number two
northbound lives 373 miles an hour
already
[Applause]
about 405 North
controllers
[Music]
405 North right now in the number hang
up
everyone
speeds approximately 70.
Notifier
on northbound approaching Cherry number
two lane northbound
okay
Facebook
[Music]
everybody's approximately 85
seconds
foreign
thank you
all right we're all the way over to the
right stand back
thank you
foreign
roll over
rotation
roller stage fire
nail shake head possibly Hispanic blue
shorts black flustered